Fair trade aims to establish equitable conditions of trade and commerce...
...between countries in the north and the south.
The concept appeared after the Second World War,...
...and received its first certification in 1988 in Mexico.
A cooperative of small coffee producers of the state of Oaxaca...
...partnered with the Dutch NGO to create the Max Havelaar label,...
...named after a hero of a Dutch novel.
The principle was simple:
The NGO buys the coffee at a fixed price...
...and the farmers, unaffected by the fluctuations of the market,...
...can then live off their work.
A part of the money is then used to finance schools and health centers.
By eliminating middlemen, distribution costs are also reduced.
The idea is also to supply good quality products while respecting the environment.
To begin with, fair trade only dealt with a few products:...
...coffee, bananas, tea and sugar.
Today, there are fair trade clothes, sneakers and even a smartphone:
in total, more than 30,000 products.
Various businesses have also become interested in the idea of fair trade.
In 2012, the sales of fair trade products were worth 4.8 billion euros...
...with 1.3 million producers and workers benefiting in 70 countries.
But the practice also attracts criticism:...
...the lack of transparency of labels which keep multiplying,...
...high prices or distributors who increase their margins on products that are in demand.